welcome everybody to the first episode
of the h3 podcast line it's actually
like the seventh episode but this one is
live on Twitch T Ford's twitch.tv /h
taboos reproductions where we'll be
live-streaming
every week Friday 3 p.m. PST unless
we're late but we shoot for that time
today we are joined by my good friend
and a sweet lovely guy talented artist
you guys know him as post Malone what's
going on he's he's the best family
family and before we begin I just want
to say that this is like my little
Schilling moment I have to do that you
know supporting show usually will have
ads but I'll say it since we're on
Twitch Amazon bought twitch and they
have this wonderful thing where if you
have Amazon Prime you can link it to
your twitch account and subscribe to our
stream for free that's literally free
money from Amazon it's the craziest
thing ever the rebel we get from that is
so awesome it makes this experience a
wonderful thing for us because we get
Chetta so if you have Amazon Prime smash
that subscribe button link it to Amazon
and we get a free subscription let's see
if we can get this podcast to 500
trillion likes I'm shooting for half a
500 trillion I'm looking for what's over
a trillion so how are you feeling Doug
I'm fantastic I'm a little hungover from
last night yeah I was there but I only
hit my snooze button once and I'm here
and I'm ready to get weird come on boy
we were originally planning to just be
mean he listens we were troubleshooting
this and I was hanging out with Austin
last night and I was like Dawg do you
want to join us
like friend of the show style like
obviously we want to have you on like
exclusive I was like let's friend of the
show this [ __ ] and Austin what time you
usually wake up like whenever this
started not not the original start time
but the start time that we just like for
for yeah so when I wasn't easy
so when I was like yo be there at like
can you be there at like 3:00 yeah and
you're like like I understand that you
made a real commitment I did I did I
asked if there was any flexibility and
he said there was and then you know I
was on time but Ethan and ela we're not
yeah that makes other people in the
twitch comments it's not my fault I'm
just a guy I have feeling not you're I'm
just people say I have really beautiful
blue eyes but I'm just a guy you're
saying you can be both
you can't beautiful blue eyes and be
just a guy you really think so no
anything yeah so okay so obviously we
don't usually drink I don't think I've
ever drink on camera
good ever like you a lot of youtubers do
like I'm getting drunk and doing some
wild stuff I'm gonna kiss a boy I don't
know people do when they drink but today
in honor of Austin coming out we got a
30 pack of Bud Light we have like how
many cigarettes can we see like I think
half a carton five packs including this
one I'd say 100 100 ciggies
yeah in total this is class this is
class at its finest mmm for it nothing
like walking around with five packs of
cigarettes in a little plastic baggie
you should tie that around your
waistband we should have like a like a
satchel like a you know how people in
the medieval times would carry their
coins in such a going purse but like
fine leather like beautiful embroidery Z
maybe some like torched patterns on them
yeah let's go siggy pouch Ziggy pouch
you see Ziggy
pouchy here's the thing though I like
the plastic bag look I think I like that
if we could just get Gucci to make a
plastic bag yeah it's like it's like
kind of like garbage you know where you
can't tell if it's helmet if it's
homeless guy or fashion you never played
a game on you could play that game on
the street like it's like a homeless or
is he just fashionable as [ __ ] it's the
Ethan money people people know I'm not
fashion
they just know I'm homeless is fun it's
done Ethan he needs to give some Gucci
sandals yes good you thought I was I was
telling Austin he was trying to she's
trying to break me down we've been
together now for ten years and now all
the sudden she's trying to break me down
she's trying to get me stuff like some
bands I said the first yeah I noticed he
looked very sad wearing bands today
which isn't like the epitome of style
but it's better than what I was wearing
which was like old man potatoes on my
feet so did you change those this
morning is that what you check out these
kicks boy it's literally just a van
those are on fire but we match but I'm
sure this I look like a mental patient
Austin put this picture on Twitter of
him with glowing
yeah I did look very godly I look like
Hercules can you pull that up can't show
the TV I want to see Austin glowing but
maybe with the anyway so I have a funny
story from from yesterday we were
hanging out I I didn't tell you guys why
I hate Los Angeles I like Los Angeles
but there's a couple of things I hate
about Los Angeles here for example we're
hanging out at Austin's house there's
all this [ __ ] on on the counter we're
drinking we're smoking we're having some
last couple of guy who's Zeus Zeus
laughs riots romps there's like a little
chocolate on the counter and I'm like no
chocolate right I'm happening I got a
little buzz let's have some chocolate
and like when there here's the thing
whenever you eat a chocolate or a
beverage you take some anything from the
counter or someone's fridge you have to
check it make sure there's no THC right
that's California in California have to
make sure there's no THC on random
snacks so I look at this thing and I'm
like yeah it looks like a little
chocolate give it to ela she eats it how
was it by the way of course I was trying
to it was just one little bite I was
like Eli put on some cows baby imma take
care of you know nothing about that
piece of chocolate indicated that it had
weed in it right it was small and
packets really nice
like a tiny cube of chocolate in a
really nice back I did wonder like who
yeah looks a little weird but like who
would Pat who go through all the effort
to package this one little bite of
chocolate but it was too late so yeah it
was such a small bite that I just put in
my mouth so it's too late once it makes
in once it makes contact you're high as
[ __ ] yeah pretty much I love it so yeah
so basically he would downstairs
chocolate and I look I I put on like my
my jewelers binocular and then I see oh
it says 25 milligrams of THC at the
bottom and then we're like we need to
leave before that time I was already
melted Ethan comes up he's like yo yo yo
yo we gotta go dude Ethan's our only
chance so I have to go right now oh no
so BER right it was our sober driver and
then all sudden she's about to start
going weird and wild with with it the
thing is we don't ever smoke
so when that [ __ ] comes on it comes hard
even afterwards was looking for it for
like it's something else right we didn't
it was it when you go home it was
blasted really she was talking to be
there for her I was drunk and like
before we left I was looking for edibles
cuz I didn't want to leave her like you
mention if you put away quicker you do
it down yeah maybe but like it was kind
of a mistake because I don't ever smoke
I don't eat [ __ ] and this morning I woke
up and I and I feel I don't understand
people who I know a lot of people enjoy
it it doesn't work for me like I woke up
this morning I feel like I have autism
so what did you do I just I
like I know I ate it I ate it some oh of
a power
yeah if someone's much par there so I
munched on someone's bar munching on
bars it's like an official like much
like I think yes the minds fight
trademark THC so I munched a bar I'm
gonna break a couple of rules oh dude
when post Malone's here we smoke we
drink we get weird I want to flip this
table I'm gonna fight Alex and then
Jason shit's gonna get weird for you so
we're gonna be drinking and smoking so
let's go I don't know if I wonder if our
lucky dude let's turn these let's turn
these business dudes on their head away
man turn them flip around once judo
throw maybe we should put a towel on the
door like a hotel or something just so
the I think we're fine
but there's like a lot of carpet that
smells gonna get like nice in here I
always think of you exactly so I'm just
trying to help you guys and give it a
little rustic house like your grandma's
house is grandma's house ya know some
cigarettes ever since I was a kid
grandma blowing smoke in my face have
you it was really you got a smile yeah
she had ashtrays all around in the house
like just very conveniently in every
room like one of the tall ones like at
the hotels I think she stole them from
hotels
cuz they were very they were very classy
very nice Wow I'm a grandma Malone
grandma
Diane grandma Diane Diane Fraser almost
I seen it Fraser mm-hmm
kateed like the TV show so growing up
watching your green oh girl oh growing
up did I say that no I suspect I was
Irish well like I was saying anyway the
point of that story about how I ate
edibles yesterday was just to say like I
woke up this morning I feel like I have
mild autism I'm learning I'm legit think
that being high feels like having
optimism you see what you see I'm just
putting out disclaimer now so you guys
know why I'm acting specifically
autistic today that's not you know
whatever anyway so where were we
so you grew up with your grandma she was
smoking around yeah well yeah I mean you
know that's that's how we get down
I think you're not good I was born so I
was born in Syracuse where's that
upstate New York but yeah Syracuse boy
Buffalo buffalo yes I was born in four
Teamster our lives would honor really
from Buffalo yeah dude I was born in
Syracuse and my grandparents lived in
like Walton and Rochester and all that
stuff and my you know my mom's side is
very like country and very loves loves
tractors and horses and stuff so they
just love to smoke anything that they
can get their hands whatever is good
yeah there's not too bad rest her soul
she was just running around and just
having fun holding me I love her to
death do you do when did you leave
upstate New York I was nine I moved to
Dallas my dad works for the Cowboys go
boys God's team America's team the roof
the roof opens so you can watch them so
God can watch them play is that right
that's true that's actually a fact the
thing is like I you would assume that
God could see through a room I know but
you know he is symbolic me think he's
like he's got flaws just like us he's
one of us he's like can you guys open
the roof watch the boys come on get bad
perspectives you imagine God and I in a
in a cowboy jersey so cool spot yeah god
is blazing I hate camel crush right now
and drinking a Bud Light I really
enjoyed your guy's enthusiasm when I
said Cowboys Cowboys Cowboys you can't
it's hard to deny the power of being a
cowboy it's true so do you have fun
memories of when you lived in New York
or like I was you know like not really
not really that much hmm it's like I
remember one memory actually a couple
memories I could tell you guys a couple
memories who want to take a trip down
memory lane I'm gonna light one of these
up in your honor yeah kill it as I don't
smoke I don't endorse smoking but when
I'm with Austin you make it's just
cigarettes ordered a lot of weed packed
into obviously based on my previous
story smoking is like the worst thing
ever
for me anyway I'd love to hear your
stories take a lap this one's a quickie
shorty shorty shorty but a quickie and a
goodie and I tried I got a snow mobile
snowboard for Christmas and I tried to
snowboard in my front lawn it's one
memory that I realized that snowy I mean
that no I mean there was there was out
literally couldn't you know you suppose
a snowboard on a hill or something yeah
it was just so yard like I was reading
some powder there's no there was nothing
yeah it's shredded um another great
memory my birthday's on July 4th
Oh every year my dad would get hella
fireworks and shoot him in the backyard
and I hated it I was so scared I thought
the cops are gonna come and arrest
everybody and one time my friend Vinnie
threw a match into the whole box of
fireworks and it just fainter it [ __ ]
Vinnie did and he were Jenkins
I just remembered that's a great fact
about Vinnie those big jeans like the
big rage raver jeans he was older than
me
I was maturing mature I was like raver
yeah yeah yeah I've seen a person those
jeans and thought like that's a normal
guy right this guy doesn't have anything
wrong with them
Yeah right but at that time I didn't
know shout out shout out to Vinnie shout
at the Vinny he sent off them now I
haven't talked to him for a minute
I hope you're still rocking those jeans
by and I hope you're still killing them
janko's bleh and he threw it and they
exploded everywhere and that's a great
story a really inconclusive story
so usually we'll have a camera set up
that we could switch to but for now
that's what Austin's this guy's cool as
hell look at the other photos of it I
did a whole flip book Wow so what do you
think when you see someone like that
what are you supposed to think what what
is he's gained on iPhones he's got
are you sick iPad minis long do you
think you could make this cool
Jenko um you know it I'll give it a try
I think that would be a great outfit for
an idiot hookah shelter puka shells and
janko's we should do a video as a my new
that's what my new albums called that
goes kind of cool the guard the fourth
guy oh that's sick he's like tilting on
the whole planet
he's plort I love holy my god it's like
a tent you could like take a nap under
it I love how they have to show him off
you know before the picture he had to
flare them all out as wide as he could
that's for sure look how big my jeans
are look at that [ __ ] bucket hat I
love how nothing matched back then yeah
nothing went together like he's got
brown grey green blue eye stuff like it
out machen I don't understand matchy
matchy so you don't want to match too
much yeah you don't want to be one of
those guys that's like blue hat blue
shirt blue socks blue you don't want to
be the type of guy to wear all like all
white to like you don't want to be white
you can pull off the mental patient look
you know I just escaped on that
excitement I'm glowing when you pull up
that picture Jay who's on the laptop you
you you plop the glowing post Malone
lead is lame look at this what look at
this there's no filter no filter really
hashtag no filter Li the gods that watch
over the Dallas Cowboys was watching
this podcast now and blessed you with a
glowing aura I look great oh I look like
Hercules from the movie Hercules
Hercules reborn
really maybe we should need to do a feat
of strength okay what do you need
well I carried this 30 pack up those
stairs and you had like a really fast
recovery and then that's surprising
surprising one minute I was back to
normal breath is it kind of incredible
so how's it like so before you retire
you got a beard so like if you first of
those you guys who don't know the story
of I'm still drinking this no I like the
flavor of just ash so for you guys who
don't know the story of post
correct me if I'm wrong but you were
doing your thing you were making some
some indie music just doing some [ __ ] on
your own yeah I was just running around
I was making at the at one time I was in
a I was doing acoustic sets at a
restaurant I was trailing gigs
yeah like gigs that give me 200 bucks
and free chicken parmesans
yeah it's great it was great I was in a
metal band making beats making a mixtape
obviously yeah it was everything yeah
and I seen some of your weird [ __ ] do I
want to watch those some of they are
weird like sketches you made yeah I mean
there's only one there's one class one
before we get into that I want to talk
about basically you were doing all that
stuff and then you made white Iverson
yeah and that where did you post that
originally SoundCloud and did it blow up
on soundcloud before youtube post Malone
old sketch now you got to type in Leon
de Chino
so you posted so anyway cut just to give
context Austin post Malone
he made this musically go to white
Iverson had it now has like almost 400
million view it's crazy why it went
massive years so you posted that
originally on soundcloud and people were
digging at the end before the on youtube
yeah so maybe I had put it on maybe I
had put it on soundcloud and youtube at
the same time but SoundCloud was really
where it started like popping really
know what I mean it's like I woke up and
then the next day it had thousands of
plays and then I think I had tens of
thousands so just completely unexpected
war night yeah my homie key put yeah so
we put out the song and my homie key
tweeted it and I guess he was [ __ ]
with him so was retweeted it and sort of
Mac Miller and I woke up and it was just
like wow all these people that I listen
to heard my song why do you feel great
crazy wild crazy cuz I never thought
that anybody would ever like and
that I've ever made so it was it was
mind book everyone probably feels that
way yeah I definitely felt that way when
we were making videos although we were
making [ __ ] that songs great humble
beginning yeah you know so oh I don't
know they may be probably the probably I
mean that top one looks good oh no is
that before click that top one let's
just see I mean four minutes that's got
to be it right this might be a whole
video but so how long did it take on
youtubes where you got this point we
have like hundreds of millions of views
how fast was that um not I mean it I got
a million views quickly cuz we shot the
video we shot the video very kind of a
long time after the song came out so the
song was already kind of pop in so I put
the video up it cost five thousand
dollars and you put like all your money
down on that yeah we'll meet my manager
did yeah so we just had the video and
then it started popping and here we are
four four times platinum
Stoney's platinum I'll cheer salamis
here yes abeer yeah Papa top Cheers on
this got him I got him
you know it's brought to you by like
when it's buh-bye loot crate is about my
pain you they should be no we're talking
to them right now they I think they're
gonna do my festival because I think
there's some legal stuff you know cuz
I'm so young and 21 so it I think you
had to be 25 right think several but I'm
not sure I haven't really looked into it
that much I just know they give me free
beer and I'm content with that cuz what
here what do you need
I mean you did you you you drinking lots
of beer that's like you sponsorship it's
good stuff I like ever since I met you
I'm I'm popping that Bud Light it's good
it's refreshing it's refreshing light
this is just turned into a Bud Light
it's alright it's alright pay me and
then I'll be great
I I think it's great but not that great
yet I could think it's better could be
better so after that one huge you like
what happened how did the how did you go
from like boom millions of views on
YouTube this song's poppin wide Iverson
to where you are now like how'd that
happen just kept doing shows they do a
lot of free shows well started reaching
out to you yeah yeah did a lot of free
shows did a lot of just marketing
running around getting my face out there
interviews all that stuff and you know
everything went great that's it because
I'm super handsome and likable and they
just say wow here we're gonna make this
guy a star and now you and you just
released your first album not that long
ago in December yeah which was a hit I
love that album yes slam shot to
Pharrell did you listen to that of the
animals last night no straight to bed I
know that's crazy man it's a real
Cinderella story it is it's really the
cheesy corniest like made it story
it's so sick cuz it's like the American
dream right it's alive and well in you
know so it is and it I feel like a lot
of people were kind of rooting against
you right yeah like who is this white
boy yeah who's this white kid trying to
come in and yeah it's wild it's live
everybody yeah this everybody hated me
everyone wanted to write you off as like
a one-hit wonder exactly but now I'm a
two-hit wonder congratulations a exactly
the exact Lee the truth is if you
to get that second hit yeah yeah I think
I think so too
and I level when people say you know
this guy's a one-hit wonder why say I
have one more hit than you do it's not
it's not easy I still don't have a hit I
think he could sell flow like in town
yeah I think we're I think that one's
coming on the way yeah let's watch that
first so you guys I don't know if you
saw this but on Twitter I never seen a
tweet honest through that may read it
had like 300,000 like yeah thousand
retweets it's wild and I've never seen
nursing that either Twitter
weather step you guys are stiii I love
it worse I told you dude I just want let
everyone know I don't know what you guys
might find there that's Anna Smith and
his family listening to my song which is
awesome we can just watch all this [ __ ]
on your yeah my feet isn't incredible
how many how many go down through the
tweets let's see how many how many
retweets you got whoa that's wild oh
that's wild
dude Trump doesn't get like I don't even
know who this guy is just how many
followers does he'll I checked when it
broke he had like 300 like he was just
some dude crazy try again
set it to Juncker done you could get out
gingka Jay John take Jim cajones and
cake doing a done
come on I was hammered in Miamian and it
was so much fun so what's the story
behind this video maybe just you to go
to youtube and type post Malone mariachi
so Brian rich chigga from Indonesia yeah
we went to show yesterday he's lost
killer super super dumb yeah he just he
came and he said hey I got a surprise
for you and I'm like okay what would he
get what'd he get and then this mariachi
band comes over and starts singing my
song and I was already hammered so it
was awesome
shouted to Brian that is badass yeah
yeah okay go rich [ __ ] yeah he posts
made it a mariachi band yeah how do you
even do that I don't know dude
everything is about someone just figured
out at a book of mariachi read book me a
mariachi band straight up like man
[Music]
let's hit the chain
Wow
dude this glove that's shirt I'm gonna
sing sure yeah no no no it's it is me
[Music]
thank you and go shorter go home yeah
this is right in front of my trailer
they gave me two trailers because I'm so
fast nothing I threw up in one so he had
to move to that other here's awesome
exactly how convenient is it really it
was a really fun time you down whole
time that's the sound is it working
[Music]
right channel just this video though not
the whole thing
see
[Music]
I think it was first my DJ have you ever
first real cool guy real cool I like
[Music]
post made it over to sing you a song
that's a hit it's true it's true this
one line that resonates with me so much
I love is work so hard forgot how to
vacation great line I know you guys know
about that that jolt your mic is playing
double is it or was for a second but I
think it's fixed is it good I had some
slap back I said this one John Lennon I
love that line but thank you and I feel
like and I feel like you're busy all the
time I am I mean y'all are too y'all
kill yeah it's crazy I hate it I don't
hate it I hate traveling I hate I hate I
love they always say it's about the
journey not the destination but it's
always the destination and we expect
exactly you didn't think that [ __ ]
Frodo and Sam wise and was like hell
yeah this is [ __ ] sick if they had the
option date exactly well here's my
question why would those [ __ ] birds
not around whenever they had to get
there yeah where the dude those Eagles
they hooked up Gandalf they went and
[ __ ] off for like 3 full movie right
you guys could have cut to the chase
dude literally put these hobbits on your
back take them to the fires of Mount
Doom drop it off just in time for second
supper second supper we didn't hold up
for the first one you know how hobbits
exactly so like yeah I mean I've hung
out with you a lot you're one of my good
dogs and you have like a massive posse -
I'm surprised you came here by yourself
today but usually you roll with like a
lot of people how is not always being
surrounded by people you know it's
really stressful because we can never
find an uber big enough for all of us
and I'm the only one that actually has
like motive with what I do I'm very
goal-driven so I say we need to get here
and I'm like okay I'm ready to go right
now
and then everybody's just sitting there
[ __ ] around and it really stresses me
out and by the time we get there I'm
really stressed out but then once we're
there I'm good
you gotta have someone to crack the whip
for you so you don't have to be the ass
won't be like guys get ready you need
like you're doing it I mean I mean like
I need like a [ __ ] guy that has a
loud voice same whip she whips my ass
somewhere in vans can you promise Eva
has the greatest the greatest lowboy
audiobooks really yeah with my accent
let me kill thinking about writing a
book about weight loss how did not be
fat Fupa Fupa reduction reduction in
three easy steps I did lose 15 pounds I
know you look great but I have a lot of
work to do and there's still plenty of
food but left over feel like actually
can't really right I have seriously
things to say about weight loss but I
don't think it's appropriate for me to
write a book about weight loss well I'm
still on the board of being morbidly
obese right the book as you're doing the
weight loss that's true that I agree I
don't think anybody's ever done that
that's it really good concert like like
like the Fupa Diaries oopah Diaries
things like Anne Frank
except Fupa only it's just like Anne
Frank buy my book today it's got me in
the Attic she makes me be quiet
sometimes just on the stair climb right
yeah just like Anne Frank I'm trying to
make some food with Diaries out soon
pre-order now I'm wondering when I'm
hanging out with you and I see your hey
you're always with like ten people and
I'm wondering are they friends do they
all work for you who are they Oh
it depends and some mix Dre works for me
your manager yeah my manager aleck
yeah alec is my right-hand man helps me
with my day-to-day sorry sorry
apologies Tila he Don is a producer
first a DJ then everybody else is my
just my friend Ashlyn's they're running
around doing ashland stuff yeah
his girlfriend sweetest it's my gal pal
she's great yeah she's she's awesome
her any you guys are good do some girl
stuff I know I told her we switched
phones last night so you guys follow me
that's some real that's a big number
okay you guys have a lot of trust
already I'm gonna respond the way you
would respond it's a new challenge
phones phone switched Ruston's like she
deleted all the [ __ ] right pictures
there's nothing bad in not too bad I
don't want her to have EULA's you got
some weird pictures of me like fully
nude just not even sexual just
completely naked for the Bupa Diaries
yeah
yes for science just take out the
[ __ ] spread wide open icon show
spread them Ethan all right what I
imagine whatever it takes to make you
happy
so what's like what would you say is
like the worst part about Fame cuz you
become pretty famous and pretty fast
what what are the pitfalls of that
freedom I want to say no not naughty
looks perfectly blocked I'm like no
matter wide we can just enjoy ela being
covered by Austin's Mike say hi ela hi
Daddy
classic classic no but um you know it's
tough it's tough traveling it's it
really takes a tear on you where it
doesn't
does that make sense yeah toll it really
takes a toll a tear at all aritaum I was
thinking about you traveling a lot
because we just went to New York and
then Sweden and that was like enough to
have like the Sweden is [ __ ] yeah
yeah the flight to just Europe is shitty
it [ __ ] you up the gun zone so it go
Polaris is that the good airline doesn't
know that that's like the the I think I
don't know if it's Delta or JetBlue but
you get a bad it's killer so we did
business on JetBlue you have to lay down
you got so you got the full battery
everything it's nice it's pretty and
that's actually nice but whenever you
get there at [ __ ] sucks because like
you said it's Honduras it [ __ ] you up
the time difference in Australia so I
could nuts no that place is not on the
moon as far as I'm concerned places like
forbidden ground seriously so you'd say
like traveling the track you do a lot of
traveling yeah I'm about to tomorrow I
go to what's today the 19th tomorrow I
go to I do a show in Northern California
and then I fly to Vegas to do another
show on the same day and I'm going to
look at my house up in North Northern
Nevada my apocalypse bunker oh yeah I
want to talk about them and then I come
back that's crazy I get a little break
hopefully I just up stuff let's go
yeah the travel I can only imagine like
you said we did it and I was dead yeah
when we came back from Sweden New York
we were gone for like two weeks and I
just came back dead dad yeah like I was
just so dad the fan meet have looked
great was that in Sweden yeah that was
nuts
we had the I don't know if you guys all
saw this but we had a fan meetup in
Sweden we just tweeted it out the day
before on socials we didn't really
expect much I was expecting like a
couple hundred people or something and
we just tweeted out the specific
location and it was in the middle of the
week at like 11:00 and I felt like post
my mom dude it was crazy no one would
come see me guys are way cooler than me
Ethan Ethan will come to myself even a
Neela will come to my selves and
people will be like I'll be walking past
and either don't be right there knees yo
yo yo that's not sure I feel like the
shitty member of a boyband did I
definitely following you and everyone
care I just like hide in your shadow
because you're hella tall they're just
like sneak behind you everywhere because
everyone knows who you are
we got a club somewhere it's like a
trenchcoat like little rascals yellow
sir
yeah well what did I say the human
Rascals and the little rascals yeah we
got you I was thinking a totem pole
human totem it's nice yeah I like that
Oh talk about the Sweden thing okay
so dude there was like two like we
showed up and there was like a hundred
people outside like an hour ahead of
time and we're like okay cool it's
normal reasonable and like the line kept
growing yeah and it like we were there
for two or three hours and the line kept
growing like longer and longer around
the building I think they ended up being
there was like 2,000 people there
god damn it was [ __ ] mad and I think
we only got to see like 200 of them shut
down the city kind of this people were
spilling out into the street and the
cars did like the Swedish guys come and
say no no no no they did no didn't
become a fire hazard sadly I was hoping
that we would check the whole stop
coming down you would have gotten
arrested for like inciting a riot or so
now I've been sick that wasn't a great
story would it give you some edge yes
some of the credentials that you've
always wanted
I need more credit credit didn't chills
could it so we only got to see like 200
people and I felt bad at the end of it I
wonder I thought we could just go walk
outside and like shake people's hands
and say what up and take pictures
because they're waiting outside it was
super cold for like three hours
sorry sorry apologies wait I don't think
I've ever heard you burp really I've
definitely heard you fart the treads act
like she doesn't fire but sometimes we
chill
you just it comes out and it's pretty
loud and I'm like oh damn girl oh it's
good way I mean I want a divorce baby
not Obama got him
dirty stinky to like surprise me like I
wouldn't expect these deadly little
[ __ ] blast bombs to come out of
heelas ass sweet girl I am NOT making
this up you cannot deny this you cannot
lock me away in the Attic like Anne
Frank we go outside at the meetup to say
what up and he love farts that's how
she's gonna get everybody to go and says
she's gonna get everybody to get into
the uber landing a live shot want to
have a segment you affording me ain't
coming you did this watch out haters
watch out haters but you never burped
that's crazy
well she drink more I want to burp out
of you today
that's the goal that's so many we walk
up front and like we cut I was just I
was seriously like blown back
flabbergasted there was it was just a
sea of people I couldn't even walk out
and I was like taking pictures
shink people's hands and we had security
there and they're like get inside it's
not safe people are throwing Pepsi cans
at us really fully loaded max yeah damn
and then we went out back to try to
escape to a taxi and then everyone
swarmed back there
could you imagine death by Pepsi can
what have you just got like stone that's
very poetic they'd end up it was being
filmed so I'm sure Pepsi would end up
using that in the commercial was there a
killer time drink Pepsi what was their
thing
their slogan and that shitty little live
for now with me slow-mo hitting in the
face to death then here on the ground
bleeding out and you gotta take one
that's it before you go my only regret
was not being able to drink more - its
[ __ ] a drink tomorrow
she's a Jake bar Pepsi anyway let's
watch that video
Woods would don't want that classic
wanna do the classic glad you have a ash
right here right there now we got to so
now I want to show you guys pre Malone
there's posts Malone which is where you
are now and this is pre Malone so let me
give a little insight before I don't
think I'm a [ __ ] weirdo okay so this
is this is my alter-ego Leon de chien
now he's big in Brazil
of course he's a big super international
superstar it doesn't really give a [ __ ]
about anything me and my friend Jason
made this for our class that's how we
got started you really yeah yeah meet
Jason is my best friend you know he
moved me out here he let me live in his
closet
Wow shout out to Jason killer so if
there was no Jason I mean I think you
did you know I don't think he did okay I
love to meet Jason yeah he's moving
around here he cuz he moved out here
then he moved to Seattle now he's out
here she was trying to do music in
Seattle well now he makes gaming videos
or he made game yeah and then now he's
he's producing and he's gotten [ __ ]
really good so I'm gonna get him on the
album hell yeah yeah keep it in the
family
yeah man it's important alright let's
watch it well roll the clip did you ever
watch Tim and Eric because this is very
yeah this is very much yeah very
inspired it's funny I think we must have
started around the same time because I
was doing like the same kind of right
and we started this funky said I made
this beat too and I wrote all the lyrics
I can't look at you a little twink ass
everyone in the whole [ __ ] world can
hear that you know bad boy bad boy bad
boy yeah I know those trails you gotta
wait for the explosions did you edit
this what no Jason did I have no I have
editing skills but I can't like do this
now this is when I had my [ __ ] bun to
the back time I bone turn my bun to the
back like a real one I'm bringing these
back he's getting a feature on my album
your eye I'll jump in for that it's
funny because my and I did jump offense
to sign me what Mike the guy who signed
me to the label I had to jump like a
fence to get into show so it's funny
that you said that I'm just talking
about gay oh it was a metaphor okay I
thought it was a literal that's Jason
did you wait what the hell he looks like
they do from Wonder Years yeah but we
can't leak rush telephone
this is some good [ __ ] like honestly
back then this comedy was on point yeah
this is good this is a nice meeting
early mean this definitely that's a
quality but you couldn't take it anymore
why don't you love me this is a great
song to if this had like real I might I
might give this you like - like breezy
or something you know something
something crazy don't worry about it
listen to this breakdown this breakdown
Skelly right now Fred Savage on the mic
[Music]
killer so those of you guys who are
listening I can't watch
you've got awesome young Austin and Lex
look at the [ __ ] explode super small
shorts and tights I don't even know
looking like Richard Simmons
yeah it's don't call it I want to say I
like that like spell code a lot more no
but I'm telling you what's 2018 short
shorts ha fresh it's coming back I seen
you in that Marriott you wanna yeah I
just worry I just love pushing the
banjee I just love pushing the boundary
nice shot
I mean you get the gist yeah you guys
good you guys can watch it at night
whatever you gotta do
so whatever gets you through the night
if you want to find it it's called why
don't you love me
that's a nice video right there me too
dan that has a million views right yeah
yeah so that was before white Iverson
off yeah this is so this is um I used to
be so cool
give me a today yeah but this is this is
when I was doing like those shows that I
was talking about this is I was
producing shows metal all that [ __ ] and
I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was gonna
do so I just put out all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I had and yeah well something
stuck but you know everything it all
comes from just a love of [ __ ] music
and just keep on rocking and trying no
matter what you get knocked down key one
[ __ ] rockin was this was this video
was kind of a hit for you at the time
right uh I think I had like 300 views
wait I thought it was like a thing
because I seen people talking about yeah
they yeah they found it and then they
were like wow this this guy might
actually be kind of talented okay kind
of the settings though look at all the
guitars yeah so that's where we used to
jam like that's where my band used to
rehearse and [ __ ] and I'm a big Bob
Dylan fan I got Bob Dylan tatted oh
you're insane I wish I could show them
you're artists are oh yeah Kyle or Ricky
by the way so Austin post has you live
with this like he's always with you your
tattoo guy yeah I keep him with me I so
when Kyle lives in Philly
Ricky lives in Dallas and I just fly him
out like almost weekly and yeah just get
tatted in the liver okay so he's not
because yeah he's always there
he's a Mike I like to get I love him I
love him to death so you are on like a
crazy tattoo
Edwin's run yeah I was talking to you
about this yesterday you plan on
covering your whole body yeah and you
had mentioned covering your face yeah
I'm gonna do my face I wouldn't say
covering but some I mean I don't have
really much going on here so it's not
like really striking so I mean I figured
like why not touch this make you look
cool
spice it up yeah spices nice thing you
know just normal-looking guys I figured
what is it you love about tattoos cuz I
am NOT a tattoo guy I think they're dope
but I don't write it doesn't and never
had anything in my brain was like hey I
want tattoos so it's like um I guess
here's a way to look at it you know you
you play you said you were a real wild
guy yeah so imagine you capped out right
you kept out a level seven we got all
them you got all the armor you can never
get any new armor and then you you quit
playing yeah so I figured um I already
have a blank canvas and I feel like I
could develop myself further so the
adventure continues Wow
so I surpassed the cap and leveled
myself up and just kept on getting this
so you look at tattoos as like almost
like self-improvement almost almost is
like keeping it interesting
hmm but I like the way it looks too cuz
I'm a little chunker so you know I feel
like that kids really slim me out like I
got fat wrists and my wrist doesn't even
really like that fat right now
that's interesting that is interesting
that was a technique and plus you get to
get dope super dope [ __ ] on you like I
have a tattoo of myself on a horse like
that is a killer
so do you did you always like tattoos
growing up yeah I've always wanted tats
but I was too [ __ ] scared my first
tattoo was this playboy when I got like
a year ago
really yeah a year ago I had no crazy I
was in the middle working on an album
and then it was just non-stop finally or
not yeah exactly like an addictive thing
yeah I find that people who get tattoos
or Genet sorry you look I'm burping I
find that people who get tattoos go on
like a kick right it seems like
addictive in a way what I don't know a
release of endorphins or you know
testosterone or something weird strange
right
it's like whenever you feel the pain is
nice it's nice whenever it's done I
think the feeling of having something
like working on something and finally
completed it I think that's really about
people we get addicted to it interesting
I think it looks cool but I like if I
was gonna make one on myself I I
no how do you decide on what you want
yeah that's time really you just
whatever everybody says like all the
spur-of-the-moment [ __ ] that I like that
I've done like I don't regret at all yet
I tattooed my palms and I won faded
because I've apt way too much that's
interesting you can just FAP a tattoo
away yeah exactly exactly exactly
Wow yeah I don't regret it I [ __ ] I
have [ __ ] Kagome from Inuyasha on my
leg I don't regret that I got Sauron
right here but he's not done yet he's
gonna be sick when I reach done
that's sick I wonder do you think if I
ever got a tattoo that I would get
addicted HeLa and just go like put like
a skull over my face he would be dope he
need that would patli things like a
sleeve I think he'd be sick with the
slave it would take the meme away though
yeah if you it's a new it's a new normal
tattoo D because right now I'm black
that white dad gooey Fupa boy I don't
know if the tattoo thing meshes well
yeah identity interested dad catches the
whole thing though like that's what tat
yeah it looks like that's interesting
little dangerous little weird little bad
boy I'm not scared to burp in front of a
lady that's right edgy I said if we do
it too we should vote me do teddy bears
I'm down to get a teddy bear I'll do
that's very hard it where do you want to
get it you want to hide it or do you
want to show it I gotta think about it
I like a teddy bear though ela has this
drawing of a teddy bear that's really
dope I get it there yeah the Teddy tear
go to drop all right let's do it
let's do a quick we'll take a break for
like five minutes I'm gonna go to the
bathroom and then we'll be right back
hey hey hey we're here with filthy Frank
aku boy Giorgio Armani and he played a
set he's on his he's on a music kick
launching his music here and we we went
to a show we missed it but we were there
we were there in spirit yeah and I
called you and I called you and it
sounded like he just got offstage
besides that we're your friend we're
like friends with like your mom shows up
some [ __ ] she's like [ __ ] out back off
well yeah and the parking there was
unbelievable
la is a nightmare we parked in
somebody's driveway yeah they're not a
can we park here just a little bit I
wonder if that would work
that might work like hey can we are you
going anywhere can we just Park here for
like an hour
you ship you're probably better off not
even asking also if it's a rolls-royce
people I like okay I wouldn't okay all
right let's get back on the record back
home so welcome back we are back from
the break here with post Malone ela
Kleiner's what up uuk liners and we have
he's not saying much but we have filthy
Frank George on the couch so if you hear
a disembodied voice that's who you're
let's not that's not
anybody it is an EVP an electronic
Dominick and so I you're fascinated by
something is this camera on because the
lights on oh the camera doesn't show it
but we're all good right rolling okay
cut all that stealth mode so you're
fascinated by something that I find
absolutely fascinating
Austin is correct me if I'm wrong but
you seem to be obsessed with like
apocalypse shelters yeah or the
apocalypse in general any guns and stuff
like this yeah vending your territory
yeah tell me about good I like tell me
about like what's what's up with that
right all right yes
am i right though yeah man and I just
you know you walk outside and you feel
shitty you feel real anxious mmm and
it's just like [ __ ] it feels like
impending
and I'm not crazy people who know me
know that I'm not crazy you're not crazy
Milou crazy but look look I haven't won
the desire for an apocalypse shelter it
seems like everyday is not that crazy of
an idea right if you can afford it right
so I'm just buying a place out in the
sticks I'm building underground imma
build a beautiful it's gonna be it's
gonna be fun until the world ends but
whenever the world ends it's gonna be a
functional you'll be lying put the fun
and functional side alive how do you
decide where to put your apocalypse
bunker so I looked at a nuclear map I
looked at a bunch of nuclear maps so
there's like 150 warhead scenarios in
2000 warhead scenarios and what does
that mean so like if they lost 150 nukes
or if they lost so it's pretty much like
like the whole country gets nuked versus
just the major cities it's almost it's
hard to find a spot where there's not a
2000 that's like but I found a spot
where there's no nukes there and there's
no fallout winds or anything so um so
where is that it is in Northern Nevada
so it says you're planning for a real
fallout I mean whatever whatever the
[ __ ] happens is on whether it's our own
government or whether it's another
government what do you thinks the most
likely scenario for you to go to your
fallout shelter yeah it's either that's
just us [ __ ] up something something
crazy something what do you see is it
something like rushed like an attack
from another country I mean I feel like
there's I mean I feel like that's
imminent you know North Korea is acting
wild you know gotta take care of this so
are we we're [ __ ] just pushing
everything pushing all the buttons
Trump's our [ __ ] Russian spy or
something whatever I don't even [ __ ]
know it
but it's just wild this is a whole
[ __ ] government's [ __ ] so so I'm
just prepared I'm taking and you know
plus I'm I love the simple life you know
I love I love to shoot guns I love to
ride vehicles and run around and drink
and smoke and kick it so you think that
let's say that it's like hundreds of
nukes drop all the major cities gone
yeah everybody's roaming the wilderness
it's like a real fallout situation but
you have this bunker you have this
fallout shelter and you're posted up
with a gun
people are crawl flying at your walls
they want to get in what do you do
independent a nice or not but there's
too many of them how many are there
hundreds okay so then we're gonna have
what we're gonna do in that situation is
I'm already gonna have an internal
operation I me of course I'm the
president of the new United
the New Republic of the United States of
America right and if people want to
approach me I'm gonna have a great
bronze statue of in front of my house of
myself good on a bear very modest yeah
I'm the new king of the new world and
then you know every planning for this
[ __ ] and come have you ever felt like
you you're destined to be something
greater more it's something you're gonna
be the one behind the nuke strapped in
not me [ __ ] I'm just gonna start I'm
gonna rise from a feet like from the
ashes like a phoenix and [ __ ] you
know we're gonna have if people want to
get in we're gonna have to have like an
Olympic Games or some show of skill
because we need we need doctors right we
need farmers we need I'm taking a
farming class - oh good yeah I'm just
you know so you're gonna have like a
hunger game this type of situation
outside your stay and if you don't make
it hey you know yeah he pairs you marry
my wallah and then like okay but how
serious are you I'm very serious this is
not a joke this is something that you'd
be genuinely are planning for yeah yeah
I mean I think it's him I mean never
hurts like I said it's gonna it's gonna
be a cool place until the world ends
with when it does I'm cool you're gonna
be good
you like okay so you guys are all
invited I don't have to Hunger Games it
out quick drop about a thousand in the
donate section you're invited to that's
not a job drop a thousand a donate
section we're gonna get your name and
address you're on the list hopefully you
don't perish we're counting on your
parachute please no pairs we're counting
on your perishing think about your
future but if you perish just your money
isn't valued exactly you're gonna be
spending that's like the whole sky you
can't just live our bottle gasps no but
that's what there's a whole scam like
[ __ ] like a bunker for like a million
bucks
hmmm like that you live in why is that a
scam because you know it's like no no
normal person can afford that no yeah no
normal person can afford that and even
if the world done does end like what is
that what are the people like running it
gonna use the money for mmm
well it's a business yeah yeah yeah
there's a lot of money in that yeah yeah
the thing is like obviously it's not a
poor man's game right I've heard that
all of the executives in Silicon Valley
like these like billionaires and what
their new hobby that they do there is
making the most extravagant apocalypse
bunker really like they compete with
each other to make goods most
extravagant and saying apocalypse
bunkers out there spending hundreds of
million bucks on these houses it's not
smart to do it in California
no not California they're all really
ever just insult right that like these
huge guys I find that fascinating cuz
these right these are not some like
fringe guys these are big smart world
leaders right and they're out there
making no apocalypse bunkers so we need
to hustle more Allah I know I need a
bigger we I figured we've got one and a
half week that's it are we supposed to
change the title of this stream I think
we can change it afterwards of the
broadcast because I'm logged in but I
don't know how to that's fine okay let's
keep it riding yeah right oh so you have
everything cool go so you have like I
heard you talking about you have like a
government plan you have appointed
people in advance yeah well I mean I'm
just trying to get a little
infrastructure laid out it's important
it is cuz you can't just be running
running around I'm mumbly jumbly you got
it and everyone's got to know what's up
what do I get like what's my title um
you will be the document of memes so
like whenever ancient or future
civilizations look at what you get up
they dig us up and they find all the
memes in my pick me
exactly Ethan Bradberry will be our
Jesus in Bradbury they find pictures of
him just like this like this was an
important person this man this guy did a
lot of things will have big mosaics of
him with just everywhere so do you think
do you think it's worth it to like build
underground bunker for like a if la gets
nuked in LA no you buried deep under the
earth cuz what do you you need to be
able to roam their their world right
yeah I mean there's too many [ __ ]
people here they're gonna [ __ ] come
in and rigor it out whatever or la just
sinks into the ocean mm-hmm that's
helped amidst it in just earthquakes
rattle your world huh la is a dangerous
place kind of earthquakes are scary you
just don't know when it's gonna hit you
never been through earthquake heavy yeah
I've been you have where well there was
one in New York when I was a little kid
um how big was it you remember it woke
me up
mmm I fell it dropped like stoplights
and [ __ ] oh wow it was nice it was a
nice little rocker a little shake rattle
and roll yeah just a little shake bacon
rattling grow are you are you scared of
earthquakes nah I don't think so and
they tell you not to go into the street
but I feel like that would be the safest
way the safest or like an open field
maybe not the street well I know but if
you have like one storey houses all
around you just go into the street
what's I guess it's kind of fall on you
I guess it depends if there's like
street lights I guess I guess a pretty
fastened in though I guess the cables
yeah like the cables of the power like
they're come down and [ __ ] zapped you
or something yeah that's all I could
think of
I don't you've seen our house we are on
a hill yeah you're [ __ ] I seriously
think every night when that because
we're all waiting for the big one right
here in California been a while since
I've had a big boy earthquake it's gonna
happen our house is sliding down the
hill we will be perish so Mario that
happened to Mario Lopez doubtlessly yeah
crazy it's like demolished
wait when did that happen like I don't
know the last big one but he he's a lot
all right yeah he's great still very
handsome still the extra extra in every
[ __ ] hotel
trying to sleep in the morning you know
now he's new at that up EULA
he does that [ __ ] um Mario wait Mario
Lopez yeah mother Bell yeah - so he does
the thing in the hotels whenever you
watch a movie on the hotel TV and then
you fall asleep with the movie you just
wake up two [ __ ] extra like a brush
shut the [ __ ] up dude damn you do travel
a lot yeah Mario Lopez falling here I
got Mario Lopez in my [ __ ] brain did
Mario Lopez I feel like I see him and
all the B level [ __ ]
yeah was he in sharknado no but like who
was when I was a kid oh yeah Mark Cuban
what's he yeah my Q innocence are like a
billion 803 yeah
he's the owner of the Mavericks why is
he doing sharknadoes because I guess
he's on Shark Tank he likes so they
figured it's a cameo for yeah that makes
sense it's a perfect fit you know it's
just works am i right I remember when I
was a kid I got rassled into this like
scheme where they they're like hey
you're a beautiful kid and we want to
make you a star mm-hmm and then they
finger your [ __ ]
that does happen a lot of people not me
but they brought they brought us out to
the future that's another story but I'll
get into that later so they bring all
these kids out to this shoot in LA they
take your picture it's like a they just
grind you through let me take a bit to
it and they they charge you like 100
bucks per pop and they have no
connections it's just a giant scheme Sam
to be like you can be famous come down
and let us take your picture around your
box and Mario Lopez was there he was
there selling point he was there at the
end shaking everyone's hand so they paid
him to appear at this scam and that was
when I knew Mario Lopez
he's gonna perish when it all goes
that's what you get maybe he's working
for that apocalypse bunker but I was
surprised because I used to watch Saved
by the Bell a lot and I was like damn
have the mighty have fallen even at a
young age of seven I was like this [ __ ]
is not dignified I think it's crazy in
the subject matter on those old shows
were actually kind of [ __ ] weird
mature and he never got him you never
got it when you were a little
you know it's like I was just watching
[Music]
it's the show with George Coleman George
Foreman George Foreman the little one or
the big one
Lulu because George Gary Coleman's the
little one what you talking about Willis
yeah yeah that what's that show what you
talking about Willis show yeah and then
they did the guide the bike shop kept
sorry
he kept on bringing this are you the guy
at the bike shop kept on bringing him in
and he was like a little raper they had
a whole like pedophile episode we made
them take up their shirts and like write
each other or seems like we showed it on
t that I pull that out and I was just a
little [ __ ] growing pains
growing pains I think okay that is
totally mind-bending you're right Batman
90s they had episodes about pedophile
crazy like kids don't get roasted no
other thing I'm with more than like time
worry : pedophile episode that's where
I've been Gary Coleman pedophile that
would I don't know if I want to go down
that rabbit hole
but episode I'm but on the real if I had
enough money I would be building and I
would I would build a an apocalypse yeah
cuz it's also like a getaway house
exactly it's not like oh it's just not
money thrown out exactly and if the
world doesn't end then everyone wins
anyway you get to go I want to I want to
bring all my friends out there cuz I'm
gonna have a hella hella beds and [ __ ]
everybody just come out there for a nice
boys get away and just get weird
I look up growing pain I will kill your
parents Sam I want to watch that I know
what that is
look at look up Hollywood Illuminati
proof hmm did not eleven confirmed okay
here let me I think you you've got too
much text now Gary Coleman pedophile
episode growing pain and they got too
much of that type which rowing pains
pedophile episode maybe yeah
pedophile growing pains some weird dark
web [ __ ] was okay I was sure the show
was called goerge pants no I think
everyone in the stream is like shouting
the name of the show it is different
couple different strokes like a stroke
from you as different won't you get a
stroke from an old man is different from
a stroke stroke which feels good
sometimes
oh here we go okay so he's got to give
up those kids wine no this [ __ ] is so
caught fullscreen it nice reso am i
right
can I get a kind of get a different
stroke put that I'm doing it in all
different strokes
oh this is primetime television ladies
and gentlemen
laughter oh the picture aspect is weird
he's taking pictures the fact that it's
so distorted maybe we should have a
little more wine did he say that yeah
that's what he just said what happened
it's just the video wait
what's happened what are you guys
confused about anyway just have a little
more wine
can you play what were we talking about
the pedophile [ __ ] but where did it come
from
Oh oh yeah how do we get here yeah I
don't know straight you like can you
play it I'm really I want to see where
this is going
[Music]
hold you you little Jew boy he wants to
[ __ ] you more never know
what was he a grown man at this time
he's probably yeah he's probably like I
don't know 12 13 14 15 maybe what didn't
he have a thing where yes mom
yeah okay the thing where he's small
like he doesn't age properly okay I've
been because I didn't know I was getting
confused
yeah he's older than he looked okay yeah
uh what the [ __ ] was that at the end
that was that was Satan just a little
saying cameo so that is really something
that back in the day this was brand
friendly an episode where a little boy
rides an old man and his friend there
all shirtless drinking wine is taking
pictures yeah Wow and I can't even make
fun of Pepsi without getting what the
hell it's crazy
people were a lot less sensitive back
then yeah I hate it I really hate it
people know everything nowadays it's the
worst what do you mean people know
people are never wrong and they're so
sensitive and you can never tell them
that they're not wrong that's right it's
impossible to have like any conversation
about anything does it anything
political bill gets so outraged like the
moment that we mentioned Trump I'm not
saying I support one or the other
but at the moment we mentioned Trump or
Hillary everyone lose their [ __ ] mind
and you you I just can't even talk about
certain topics because people lose their
mind it's why no it's why it's just like
like no one will ever admit that they're
wrong
it's crazy they're always right and then
even if they you have proof that they're
wrong they they won't listen and I found
it to be like on the right people push
back on the left they call them like
snowflakes and they make fun of their
safe space and stuff and I'm just
talking from objects will be the outside
I found that people on the right are
pretty [ __ ] sensitive if I mention
anything about Trump or anyone's a
little bit critical about Trump it
becomes your cut I mean that's about as
far as it goes but they get super
triggered they get super triggered yeah
and I think that everyone's a little too
[ __ ] sense
everybody's so [ __ ] sensitive on
[ __ ] Twitter any big like just
[ __ ] I didn't
did the deuce witters fad forget about
it huh it's [ __ ] crazy but just a
case in point different strokes be
talking about Uncle Jimmy who's touching
little Coleman look and I can't even
talk I can't even say anything but yeah
this was on [ __ ] TV did kids were
sitting there with their parents like
watching this [ __ ] on like a plane down
your kids and then there's no conclusion
that's it the credits roll but it's a
pretty like mature and even bizarre kind
of I mean is there's that many
pedophiles out there that you need to
like make an episode of educate your
kids you always says that there's way
more pedophiles out there then I because
to me it doesn't seem like there's that
many like child rapists out there it
seems kind of rare but yeah but surely
there's got to be like pedophiles who
aren't also rapists they just like
little boys like you you can't help like
but they don't act on it right exactly
[Music]
like hey issue interesting so it's does
pedophile mean you're a rapist or just
you're attracted to cut up all means
you're I mean you're attracted well no
see and there's a whole [ __ ] thing
and this is a very sensitive subject but
now I seen with other genders that keep
getting created every day there's a pedo
sexual are you serious there's a pedo
sexual and they're trying to make it
okay which is just not okay wait wait
wait I guess but their point is okay so
I guess the difference between a
pedophile and a pedo sexual is it or not
so here's the thing that I've always
thought about pedos well it's just in a
way I people are gonna probably kill me
for this but this is how I understand it
it's like you're born gay you're
attracted to men or women your same sex
is it the same with pedophiles are they
born and some their brains are wired in
such a way that they're just attracted
to kids
mean I can't call it but it's probably a
I would but it could probably be both
it's probably to some degree that right
but again and being a bit also just sick
people that just like to take it they
like the domination exactly yeah they
like this yeah it's [ __ ] up its what
it's kind of interesting though cuz if
you're born being attracted to kids in
the same way that like a homosexuals
attracted the same gender then it's like
I can imagine that must be a horrible
existence for them if they don't act on
it
right but I mean I mean I think it's
right for them I mean suppress those
feelings good yeah of course
counselor of course oh of course you
know that's what I'm wondering like how
never resort to molesting of course that
is a jet that is objectively wrong but
it's interesting to think like who was
how many people out there who aren't
rapists who like you said don't resort
to abuse objectively wrong it's kind of
interesting right yeah I mean it's not
if he's not you never know it's kind of
interesting I'd like to see it Louis the
Royal oh that would be a wonderful
documentary yeah I guess I wouldn't go
work me anywhere they'd be like so do
you rape kids no although there was a
wonderful Louis Theroux documentary
about pedophiles do you guys watch that
no you guys gotta check him out for
never hurt me yeah he's one of my
favorite filmmakers yeah yeah he makes
these documentaries he's he's one of my
favorite like he's one of my favorite
and biggest inspirations he does these
documentaries where he gets in real deep
and he what a Cajun name [ __ ] he is its
branches [ __ ] he gets in real deep and
he's so approachable
he's so ungentle he puts all these
people in this position were they giving
forth all this amazing information you
really get to know people through
through the lens of of him like he did
this episode where he goes to a prison
for pedophiles sex offenders and that
[ __ ] is
really dark you had episodes about
everything like hunting or Nazi akk porn
stars and he goes there's a problem I've
been seen Bravo's like medicated kids
all this different [ __ ] that he do I
haven't seen that one
Medicaid kids oh we did yeah he goes to
spend some of this family they're giving
their kid he's like two three years old
they're giving him xanax prozac and
they're giving this how [ __ ] up is
people are they given their dogs Prozac
they're like our dogs are a little they
stays on edge I'm gonna give them Prozac
not for raping just for sedation yeah
exactly
so the sorry the documentaries got
crossed so this was a documentary about
medicated America okay they did about
these people who are over medicating I
haven't feeling those pedophiles are
also probably on Prozac what's the
indication well you know you can sit in
front you sit in front of a psychiatrist
and you're like hey I want to [ __ ] kids
that like take some Prozac right I mean
it's just easy it's the easy way out
right boys take some [ __ ] medicine
man this one documentary he did when he
went to hang out with the pedophiles
there was this one guy he was so [ __ ]
he was uh it wasn't pet if I was a sex
offender he was obsessed with showing
his dick to people on the street women
on the street and yeah he's a flasher
serial flasher and he had done all like
hundreds of times and they're just like
dude you can't be in society anymore and
the guy was so conflicted like he he had
no he he knew it was wrong but he was
just so [ __ ] in the head
you remember this Gila honestly I don't
think flashing is a crime so well it's
not as bad as maybe for you I don't know
maybe he may have read if there was a I
was a woman and some dude ran up and
showed me his dick and some kids but it
seemed and he may have raped a couple
it's not it's not the action of seeing
it's the implication of like what's
coming next right it's pretty okay yeah
that's true that's why you're a big guy
you see a little dick you're like haha
but if you're a woman takes a huge
what if it was a woman flashing you I
wouldn't be mad I'd be down no but and
that's a cool thing different I love to
throw back to a social experiment this
okay so you know you've seen the
catcalling video right where the girl
walks around New York and [ __ ] these
yeah like wow you're beautiful you're
beautiful I thought it was fake I was I
don't know and then I wish she got
offended cuz guys really right yeah yeah
she got offended cuz guys are calling it
beautiful
well some guys were more creepy right of
course of course but some of them were
just like hey have a good day and use
like catcalling right it's like chalk
another one up but there's a video of a
girl walking around a park talking to
talking to guys like hey can I suck your
dick and they're like yeah sure okay
really like it's different spectrums
yeah let's break it down because it's
really interesting but I can tell you
from my experience growing up in Israel
it's probably the same anywhere but
where I grew up I would walk home like
20 minutes back from school I was pretty
young going to school and yet people
will write you up and it's obviously
like I've tried sometimes to be nice and
smiled back but then they think you're
interested so you have to be cold and
then and then they're like hey why are
you not smiling mm-hmm cuz I don't
[ __ ] like honestly there's nothing
creepier like disgusting that a man
asking a woman like smile bored I don't
know that creeps me out yeah but it's
like I know if this sounds like the
Joker
let's break that down I'm intrigued by
that and I think it's definitely an are
much more vulnerable like that's just
set it up I think it's the physicality
yeah yeah I saw a study that said 90% of
all men are stronger than then all women
all women 90% of all men are stronger
than all women it's just a physical it's
physiology so what does that mean it
just means that almost all men are
stronger than everyone okay so like
you've got the physicality and prime
like our prior
primal urges as men like you go back a
thousand years
were just raping people that's how you
[ __ ] back then right like like j2me
like if you look at monkeys they just
rape our Apes or whatever right our art
and Neanderthal cousins were probably
just raping like crazy
so there's definitely something like in
us to like conquer men wanna like great
so it's you know women are in a nature
setting like to be conquered I mean am i
right that's right and in nature
documentary setting if you go back at
that or not a thousand years more like
ten thousand years but yeah that didn't
land but I mean like Jagger back in like
the [ __ ] days of like pillaging and
marauding and Vikings and [ __ ] they'll
just go and [ __ ] steal all your women
yeah all right with them and [ __ ]
right exactly so even Knights like
[ __ ] medieval times like in killings
and [ __ ] they go bless you Jesus I'm
gonna rape this [ __ ] crazy it's crazy
it's [ __ ] nuts right that's right
that's right it's the oldest profession
yeah let's yep no one gave a [ __ ] so I
think a lot of stuff about modern
society is like because we've evolved
societally we've evolved beyond that
[ __ ] sorry and so we're fighting against
our primal urges and a lot of modern
society is us trying to fight against
our primal urges has become better right
and for the whole yes for the whole
selfish because rape is is [ __ ] up we
all acknowledge that irony but it's like
a primal urge that a lot of people have
so it's like I did I think it's so you
want like you mean like is it a matter
of society says it's okay to rape first
you have an innate desire to raise right
okay yeah like so is it yeah its
permeate isn't that the biggest mystery
of the human race
it's probably both well sure if but I do
think that animals in general not just
humans but animals in general it's like
god you're looking down with your
Cowboys Jersey tell us if its nature
block this conversation out god but I
think that in the animal kingdom the
only one prime objective of animals is
to procreate stuff [ __ ] and [ __ ] out
babies so in that like primal sense
that's it if you can if you can rape and
plant your seed you're successful
species because back back to everything
that's what all animals do like I said
you can't walk into my house without
getting just on by my dog I was in there
yesterday night one minute your dog's
[ __ ] the [ __ ] instantly yeah exactly
but it's just it's not like his fault
but I think as humans I think that we're
just super [ __ ] developed we ran to
the point where we think about we have
empathy instead of exactly we're
self-aware yeah like a dog we'll just
[ __ ] whatever it sees but we've come to
the point where we're still animals we
want to [ __ ] whatever we see but we know
it's wrong right so we battle it's a
battle of intellect is crazy
yeah this conversation bad should we say
it's interesting isn't it I can already
see people taking stuff out of context
whatever this is what it is like I just
accepted it we're just talking this is a
podcast right this makes me want to have
a radio show I'm like AM radio like we
got this late night all of us and just
so we have everyday just going to work
sounds fun I like radio show doc you
don't need it we have it that's what
we're doing okay well I want to be a
permanent and gentleman to the show come
anytime come anytime YouTube and I
already put my seat right you want to
say asking for you to be on ok now he's
fine so who the [ __ ] is the homeless
person they they can't see they wouldn't
be able to see you anyways because of my
mic stand
that's wish we have a swell Ellis here I
mean Georgia so what they want guys
please please donate for George one
thousand dollars for George this is your
gets 10%
I'm already shaving 80 off the top of
everything 80 is pretty steep I never
heard of that you know you know what's
crazy easily goes what right I don't
know if many people will identify with
this what I think is interesting in new
media digital media the normal cut is
30% really in traditional media as you
know it's temperature yeah so all like
all the new media ship people are
getting killed 30% of the time is it why
do you think that is they can yeah
that's new it's illegal yeah so it's new
so they're like we're taking a risk so I
want it's not even that it's just they
can't traditional media there are laws
there's an actual laws it says you
cannot take more than 10 percent right
so digital media isn't protected in that
same capacity why is it everyone saying
beep in the catch everything kind of
interesting I think we made some strides
I think we across him anyway yeah that
was interesting
anything you want to talk about George
absolutely um back to the bunker thing
totally agree Stephen Hawking was just
saying that we only have a hundred years
hundred years
realistically yeah and I mean quick and
Steven Hauk yeah it's important and I
think you you definitely need a bunker
but also I think it's important to have
your very own seed bank right yeah you
should collect about sperm know what you
can't you can do that too but mainly
different spots he's gotta have all it
no just just just have all your seeds
ready to go right and when you're ready
to bounce you just you just you know
plant seeds where it wherever there are
no people they have one of those in the
mountains somewhere in there right
that's right yeah okay its nuclear prove
it
the seeds are gonna be the new currency
so everybody's gonna buy [ __ ] with see
anything Bill Gates own cuz even even
[ __ ] in that like you said bottle
caps no one is gonna give a [ __ ] about a
dollar yeah no one is gonna give I'm not
gonna give a [ __ ] about this watch
that's not a great value exactly so but
a seed something that can sustain life
and is it is actually good because you
can go to green thumb right now and buy
seeds as
yeah so get all your seeds yeah you know
yeah see these are expiry right never
the right never expires either yep holy
[ __ ] you guys keep rice for hundreds of
you do you own seeds Georgia dude I have
a seed bank like I really I have a bag
full of seeds at home actually no joke
what are the most value a corn are the
most valuable seeds well first of all
like like tomatoes rice like can grow in
like a bunch of places you got to get
like all the dry seeds I know I have
like basic like you know green pepper
you know
onions onions can grow like wild onions
the groin I could eat corn every day I
could equip more rice every day one
grows on dry dry places you know you can
grow up cactus if it's super dry like
like a low type stuff you can eat those
you can stay hydrated and that's like
the whole thing it's if you are prepared
it's not gonna be that bad if you have
solar powered you can still run it even
after the world's over you can run a
television and eat rice and corn and
just drink water every [ __ ] day and
you live a good life out about that seed
thing seeds yeah you know C's is where
it's amazing I'd collect them like right
now we will send you a personalized seed
bag with your favorite veggies and
fruits including postpones cement as
well
would you sell your semen how much
that's what I'm wondering
without a thousand dollars um like a
Mille I'd have to do a little background
check to you want to make sure yeah I'll
do a million dollars per batch you don't
want no thought no i don't i wanna i
want a nice classy sophisticated ladies
a lot better rate than they give at the
current all right sperm big random jizz
everywhere Alaba jizz so what was the
context of Stephen Hawking saying like
we had 100 years up cuz he said some
nutty [ __ ] recently that I'm not I don't
write he says he saw some black hole
[ __ ] that's like kind of off sometimes I
heard him talking about even if you
believe in aliens I do I don't believe
that aliens visit earth I think that as
far as we understand physics it's it's
not possible or at least it's not very
like but see that's like think about
think about an alien okay everyone
wants to think about aliens as like the
little short gray guys would be a big
eyes but that's just a human-like
depiction yeah it's like so it's like we
don't even know like in Halo or
something right right
aliens have guns in that game that they
use with their hand but who are we to
say that they have a body part that we
don't even [ __ ] care him they could
be like yeah exactly they could be
exactly like Rick and Marty or whatever
yeah yeah or the [ __ ] fart but you
know who's to say that just because we
can't comprehend it that they don't have
that [ __ ] like they can't do that
from where they're I guess the question
well as we understand physics
it seems really unlikely that they would
come because the closest like habitable
star planet that we found is like 10
light years what if it's not planetary
what if its dimensional yeah it's
possible it's possible I just don't know
why would they come like do you believe
in like Close Encounters like people
have been abducted and [ __ ] III think I
think that there's weird [ __ ] that goes
on [ __ ] every day cuz here's the
thing if people were you hear all these
stories about people being abducted it's
always like weird desert people like
people they're always a little screw
loose and there's never been any proof
like if you're on a spacecraft desert
people it's true they a little screw
loose like grab something from the plane
take a picture of it there's never been
any actual proof it's just a lot of
anecdotes by people who hang out in the
desert looking for UFOs all night I mean
[ __ ] I think it's super [ __ ] engine
and their [ __ ] that like have you seen
the videos of the [ __ ] like trumpet
sounds like [ __ ] in the sky I've
heard it's [ __ ] terrifying we find
that capable it's terrifying look up
just like I think yeah what are they
called some body is just government sky
something alien sky is some explanation
for like it how it occurs naturally well
they say it's [ __ ] tectonic plates
but I've never really heard of
technically they can't explain it well
if did yeah tectonic plates moved and
why would it in the sky yeah I've heard
that it was like some kind of
atmospheric pressure like gas yeah I
could so it sounds vocal though it
sounds
really never heard how do you call it
gives me chills what are they called
they're called lick up strange noises in
the sky it's like it really sounds
apocalyptic as [ __ ] it's terrifying
actually never is it crazy
something about a trumpet pink guys in
the air Liam he's an alien he's odd
trumpet just type like space our sky
trumpet or some [ __ ] I think they say I
never hear saying it's fake but dude
it's well that's my doubt yeah let's
take a look at it nuts alien sky trumpet
oh there there that's it at the top of
six minutes alien butt six minutes of
this so this is gathered I just want to
hear it once 1.5 million people are done
with this oh wow that is [ __ ] this is
a Sookie Mozilla yeah hold on guys we're
trying to make sure you guys can hear
this war the world fake is everybody
saying it's fake but I don't like I mean
I don't know what should I do
we should sample that oh he said yeah
you're fired so yeah we make a fire
great beat but I believe in did I
believe in aliens it's just too much
[ __ ] like there's no way that look at
this chat think just got like this cut
it doesn't matter even if it's a little
harsh
can you hear it I can't hear but we
can't hear complicated stuff you know
and like I've seen like even like the
personal here we go you got it
so this is just a video that when you
like that is the same for the world this
guy's just [ __ ] his pants right now
I hope I have a hard time believing
that's real
no but it's everywhere I mean that's
true everybody you could fake this
anyway easy but I mean well if you like
seeing like at the first night I was I
wouldn't say the first night the first
week I was here in LA right so I go over
to my friends that I had just met at a
party and to make some music and [ __ ]
and and we go there and I we I'm pulling
up and there's just a [ __ ] big old
[ __ ] flash like the biggest flat like
it filled the whole sky white and I was
like dude what the [ __ ] is that like
what the [ __ ] is that and then it
happened a [ __ ] Ganon it just [ __ ]
filled up like literally it looked like
daytime but it was mill and night and I
just no clouds nothing bro I don't I
don't know how to explain it and [ __ ]
and the thing is like okay whenever I
was like the x-files it's crazy [ __ ]
like it's loose my thing like I I've
encountered [ __ ] like that before
but you you always got to be like what's
more likely let's say what's more likely
to our puny human brains like our
insolent human brain it's not more
likely that there's a alien from another
dimension that can't be the likely
excellent think about our unlikely [ __ ]
that happens yeah but it's not the most
likely that's true whoo more likely is
maybe some kid with the giant floodlight
that's flying filling up the whole sky
was it not lightning no I mean that's a
trip I liked it when's the last time you
heard lightning or seen lightning in LA
it happens yeah I was here I mean it
happens lightning well what's more I
miss that by the way you can have
lightning without clouds so here what's
more likely lightning in the sky without
clouds rare very rare or aliens from
another dimension also very rare even
we're far as I know as far as I have no
clucking questions I can't call it
probably a prayer know maybe that bear
more likely to be
hmm echoing throughout the whole [ __ ]
sky I've never had like a really intense
like close encounter so what happened to
you
I'm said I never have had like a release
oh no but you said you've seen some
stuff yeah like where I see a light or I
hear something that I can't explain
do you believe in ghosts that's what I
was yeah I I used to live in the most
terrifying [ __ ] I didn't live there
my friend lived there so he used to his
name's Danny Johnson he used to be the
number one Guitar Hero player in the
world
Wow [ __ ] killer at guitar i watch the
real goods are now he cuz he wants a
cigarette Church
I would love one how do you keep on
asking those from me I got you but get
all the supply know you want to smoke
for the people at home no it was like a
fetish for that Brazilian I'll be there
responsible don't smoke fires fire they
were giving me comps on that I really do
so I must I must have done something
right look like an escaped mental
patient we're talking about go swag you
look like a ghost
I am ago I was glowing - what about just
what if like he turned the camera and
I'm just gone I way I was never here I
would question my sanity for sure
well give her a question your sanity Oh
surely everyone does right yeah I used
to think I was like going schizophrenic
when I was going into college was that
like crazy anxiety that was terrifying I
feel bad for people who are like oh yeah
they can't control it you know what I
mean and like they push people out of
their lives by being that way but they
can't help it so it's really unfortunate
it's like what are the saddest things it
is yeah especially when you know someone
who was like a normal bright person and
then when they come and the disease
manifests itself all of a sudden it's
like crazy how do you deal with that
like so sad Wow anyway a little sad
anyone else let's get back on those
pedophiles that was weight cheerio oh
yeah so yeah Gus stories what are you go
yes
I he he lived in this house he lived in
a house not too far from me where in
Grapevine Texas okay I would go over
there every once in a while I can
Khurana I can chronologically tell you
everything that happened until the last
time that I saw me here because I was
not [ __ ] with it this is some Blair
Witch [ __ ] no this is Tara this was
literally the most terrifying [ __ ] I
can't wait I'm good
we were talking about this we need to go
full chest cam into like an abandoned
Asylum and oh it's going on Austin had
this idea that we'd go to a spooky I
thought you're talking about like a
spook house but you want to go to actual
haunted place I'm so down
show me yeah let's do it I don't believe
I'm not a believer you're not no not
okay so I'm scared I'm a believer are
you believer well you know I believe in
like demons and [ __ ] I think negative
energy and wait do you believe in demons
like in a religious sense you know yeah
I don't know do you believe in angels
I don't how can you that's no I think
what you do I think naked naked itself
is it's very point the negative ones
they're the ones that bar I think I
think negativity in the world is very
powerful like oh yeah you're a negative
person negative shits gonna happen to
you well the negative stuffs what has
they pack if there's angels then they're
just doing your job
their job you don't just like the news
or something bad happens that's what
that's what you remember I'll get a
thousand comments on YouTube 98% of them
are like wonderful kind people but it's
the 2% that it like sticks out and
bothering right you're ugly damn that
[ __ ] gets me every time you're ugly man
that gets me every time
okay so the first night I went there he
his dad was like a contractor something
lived in a very nice big house so you
walk in there's the big living area and
he has like 30-foot ceilings I want to
say okay very high maybe 20 I don't know
high ceiling very high ceiling so and
then you walk in there's a winding
staircase that takes you up to the top
deck so there's a like ledge right here
and here's the living room
and up here was kind of like a
recreational gotta if you will that
overlooks the overlooks you go up the
stairs you have a recreational area that
overlooks
entrance ya got 20-foot ceilings so I'm
up there and I'm sleeping it's like late
at night and the relation really in the
morning yeah cuz they just had a couch
out there as my first time staying there
got it now get this as a precursor to
everything the whole family the mom the
dad and the two sons locked themselves
in their room together every night
what yeah well no wonder you're scared
shitless has a horrible way to like yeah
they have their own rooms but they lock
themselves in a room together yeah
because I think I just assumed because
of how terrifying the [ __ ] house is
did they lock skip go down they bought
the house but no if you together I give
you together I feel like that's way it's
feel where I feel way better right right
right but but they bought the house
knowing that it was like I think it was
built I think wow they built it and they
how can you build a first or just
whatever's around like either either
like Indian burial ground yeah I mean
[ __ ] like that you know without
overgeneralizing it into plastic exactly
so something like that okay but um I
guess that was the actual say up older
guys it was a new house on an Indian
burial ground right right yeah so cool
so the first night I was sleeping on the
couch and like so say if he dropped a
bowling ball on a marble floor that
sound that it would make just a huge
just a huge [ __ ] like ball I heard
that on the underneath me so like I was
so the ceilings are 20 foot high I want
you to tell me how that [ __ ] happens
it woke me up and I was like bro bro
okay so that's happening me okay yeah I
mean what so again I go back to like
this what's more likely a [ __ ] a
haunted house or maybe like a picture
fell or something it was underneath me I
felt it was there was like so is like
someone dropped a bowling ball on the
floor but onto the ceiling but also you
were sleeping so maybe that's true okay
but I'll keep on going I'll keep on yeah
keep going and then so we'd go there and
I went I went home after that I came
back that
like the weekend after I was in school I
was like 14 and we we knew that some
crazy [ __ ] was going on we yeah yeah
they were like this [ __ ] is crazy you
know like oh yeah and and so we sit down
and then we hear like a noise like a
like a stop like a boom right behind us
and then we're like oh [ __ ] okay we know
it's creepy but let's figure it out like
let's see what's going on and then we
were like okay let's keep on playing I
broke my cigarette
we were rapping about that last night
yeah I know broke my cigarette but let's
keep on playing and then it gets [ __ ]
closer and then we're just like okay
[ __ ] this we go into the corner hang out
all night the cat sounds like she's
getting thrown again animal dies scary
like dying like going crazy like all
that [ __ ] okay we stayed up until the
next morning where our parents could
come and pick us up and then the next
time we went there I was determined to
[ __ ] figure [ __ ] out okay it's like
okay let's get to the bottom of this
right right so I got I downloaded a
white noise machine what is that it's
like it just plays static at different
frequencies what's the purpose so maybe
you might get like a disembodied voice
or something wait what what's the find
they do that [ __ ] with the radios yeah
right change the frequencies and they
can you're hearing what's in there yeah
like it's probably like it could be
[ __ ] yeah I was okay no I'm what
that is so we went upstairs cuz I got my
white noise machine I turned it on we
went upstairs I started feeling like
sick like literally like the sickest I
could ever [ __ ] be like I said oh no
we're yeah I don't know where I felt
like I had like the worst headache I was
cold as [ __ ] it felt like the flu you
had she cold shivers yeah I felt like I
had the flu okay and I've never like
felt that bad in my life and and we
sweat and sat down in a room and [ __ ]
did the white noise and we didn't hear
[ __ ] nothing happened but and whenever I
went downstairs I felt completely better
and I'm not even like this [ __ ] is
really [ __ ] crazy and I know I wish
you guys are there
and I know it's hard to believe that
this next parts the [ __ ] kicker okay
and this is the crazy [ __ ] that's ever
[ __ ] happened to me in my whole
entire life so they had because you met
Preston yeah he's the guy that put me
onto your stuff he's a crazy
[ __ ]
okay he was there too and my friend
Jason moszer that's the guy I met
briefly at your house yeah okay the
drunkie drunkie guy love you Preston
appreciated and he was telling me about
he was telling me about all the [ __ ]
that they would catch on the cameras at
the house and all the [ __ ] that Danny
would tell him about and [ __ ] and he
said that this so there's a big the
house is huge there's a winding driveway
here's the gate here's a pond and all
around it is woods so all around in his
woods and he said they would see people
walking along the edge of the woods
that's creepy like white like white
people white walkers like eggs
I mean [ __ ] like like that that's
terrifying and we the dogs the
neighbor's dogs he had hella dogs like
just like 15 dogs now I wouldn't say 15
5 no [ __ ] what kind of weird they would
bark they they started barking crazy
like crazy like sounded like they were
dying so we go outside and [ __ ] look
and we don't see anything and then we go
[ __ ] inside and then we're [ __ ]
still looking at the window and [ __ ] and
there's [ __ ] like four people on the
edge of the woods just like four all
night but they're but they're like why
yeah but they were solid like so wait
holid they never moved no they'd say
they're all no is it possible that it
just was like the lighting and the tree
like you think if you went out there
maybe it would make sense if you looked
at a more but like that my point is like
maybe it was just a weird like maybe all
I know is that was the most terrifying
place that I've ever been to Wow so I've
never experiencing like that but I'd
like to cuz I want to know I want to
relate that's so creepy I tried to go in
Seattle but all the places we went to
were shut down like they got demolished
what's your stories George I don't I
don't have I'm I'm fortunate enough to
not have those stories but like I hear
stories from like close friends who
would have like no reason to lie right
yeah I mean right and I've like I have a
close friend who he was when he was
young he was bathing with his sister
right you know you know kids yeah yeah
and and okay not Gary Coleman Diff'rent
Strokes and and the the baby sister
would would point to the edge of the
bathtub and be like there's another baby
covered in blood every time they went in
the bathtub you know and it's just like
weird [ __ ] like that like children are
scary too yeah they're more exact they
exactly exactly the exact opposite of
you they will sit there and be like wow
this is I don't have any other reasoning
for that yeah yeah have you ever had
anything like that ela no Israel ghosts
should be ghosts in Israel only and
stuff people know it's the Holy Land
though there's a lot of deaths
I heard the wall was crazy the Wailing
Wall yeah I heard that was like there's
a weird I've been there a couple times
II there
um I think you like I'm so skeptical
I've been there a lot of times right
it's really just kind of what you make
of it I think a lot of people can create
a sense of feeling and purpose inside
themselves that's so powerful that it's
real
right you know mm-hmm for me I was there
I mean there's a lot of energy there
there's like the wall we're talking
about the Western Wall in Jerusalem
which is the story is it was like the
only remaining wall of the most holy
original temple that the Jews built that
was torn down by the by the Romans so
it's like the most holy place in
Jerusalem and the thing that's crazy
about the wall in Jerusalem is that
right above it is the most or one of the
most holy places for Muslims which is
the house it called the Temple Mount or
some [ __ ] the Muslim the place above the
western wall with the gold dome it's
called
anyway it's yeah I haven't seen aliens
there but there's a wild there's a wild
energy there because and then you have
the most holy place for Christians the
holy sepulcher Sepulcher where Jesus
base apparently ascended to heaven from
there after he died and that's like the
spa and it's all there it's all in like
1/2 a mile radius it's all there that's
a lot of energy it's some sort and it's
weird and wild places that's why so you
wonder why it's all there I mean because
of history but why they're like it's
wild so there's yeah something special
there's definitely some weird [ __ ] about
Jerusalem because everybody's been
fighting over that the Christians the
Muslims Jews every thousands of years I
don't know why it's not that [ __ ]
great there it's not that great I mean
objectively speaking it's not that great
they want it's not it's not big it's
strange I wonder if there was like a
really important trade hub cuz it's
right on the Mediterranean well actually
Jerusalem's not it's inland yeah there's
no legitimate reason for why anyone
would care about Jerusalem it's a
[ __ ] I mean it's a nice I mean for
[ __ ] thousands of years it's crazy
why you should go yes I recommend people
to visit I love to go Jerusalem is a
super interesting town man but like when
the first time I was there I was super
surprised by all the check like you hear
about the check points and the walls and
all this stuff when you're driving to
Jerusalem or pastor aslam to the Dead
Sea it's just like miles and miles of
barbed wire fence really that you know
you block out the the West Bank and Gaza
and [ __ ] like that and it's real man
that's just like so that's right is that
because of all the like terrorism like
I'm yeah like this like the artifacts
like the ancient architecture and [ __ ]
like that
because I noticed in Rome I went to Rome
and then armed guards everywhere like so
there's well okay so no those walls are
relatively new they built them like 15
20 years ago thing was in in Israel for
there was a period of like twenty or
thirty years where Caffe bombs suicide
bombs on buses and cafes were like
averaging the whole country when I was a
kid yeah like they were just blowing
[ __ ] up like I know spawns and [ __ ] yeah
it was just every every week man it was
like 20 deaths just yeah don't go to the
mall like yeah like it was like everyday
if you if you're about if you want to go
to like the mall then my parents
especially my dad would know you're not
going it's doing to public like it can't
risk is real hardcore that's how it was
yeah and then so I'm not saying I
politically I'm not endorsing one side
of the other I'm just getting an Amber
Alert you just get an Amber Alert can we
get less spooky right now it's a ghost
alert I didn't get one but I'm they they
come in waves can we not get Amber
Alerts when we're talking about this
what does it say anyone lookout for a
Toyota Corolla anyway so again I'm not
I'm not politically aligned with anyone
but this is just a matter of fact that
that [ __ ] was happening every day and
when they built this wall checkpoints
then it stopped it stopped so Tara so
like suicide bombs and is inside of like
brought Israel proper whatever you want
to call it is like gone like that they
completely eliminated it so for better
or worse whether you disagree with it or
not
that what the checkpoint in the walls it
effectively worked for Israel I mean it
[ __ ] over the Palestinians but just a
matter of fact it's interesting let's
take a break I gotta pee we're back
welcome back great to have you
we're back what's good I'm gonna have
I'm gonna have one more beer grab me a
fresh one more cigarette
here you go bye George do you want a
beer one beer one sick no not really you
can see here when we when our child gets
breast
want you there oh I'll be there no I
want you to do it honest I want you to
do it invite you to anything baby
showers anything I'll bring the the
tightest gifts oh yeah I will I will
actually do I've I believe are you yeah
I'm a good gift giver and my baby
showers like I've been to like to you
been what do you bring what's a good
gift for a baby shower like I usually
you know like onesies with like funny
things like you dad always like yeah you
know like and the people that are having
babies at that age you know they'll
appreciate right oh man I can't wait to
get a baby
Papa just make him wear [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that's like that's the greatest
thing I really love that yeah yeah you
just dress him like absolute clowns
yeah they don't know yeah and that's
what like that's why people do people
who can't have children they do with
their dogs life is a game of dress like
domination you rave anyway I'll make you
wear whatever I want you to wear I like
that Papa bless you bless you don't
worry about it all right well we've
talked about ghosts talk about
pedophiles we talked about pocalypse
bunkers what's left we all gonna go eat
some dinner
smell you later from Elim
we've never posted a podcast like this I
wonder if it's good whoa I wonder if
it's like listenable you should usually
usually will have someone in here for
like an hour or two and then we'll edit
it down to 30 minutes of what I think is
like the best conversation but I also
know that by doing that you cut the
spirit of the podcast out and you kind
of defeat the whole purpose of having a
podcast yeah so I feel like this is our
first true podcast I'm gonna post it in
its raw form
but I also part of me it's like is this
watchable I don't know I listen I like
it I would have watched it and then also
I would have gone to sleep to it I said
kind of cause it's kind of like soothing
it was very soon yeah you guys I mean
that's what pot that's the thing I'm
grappling with his podcasts are meant to
be more they're kind of boring right
they're boring it's just people talk
yeah yeah you just meant to kind of tune
out it's a different type of content
yeah it's hard for me to grapple with
yeah and that's why we made a separate
channel now we're not gonna put it on h3
because it's just so different
yeah that's why we felt so compelled to
edit it down to like 30 minutes max
because you don't want to post a
three-hour long clip to h3 and then
people watch it like for not a lot and
it [ __ ] your channel up
what's this video you can post now oh
you can post like 10 hour video it was
500 hours
I mean I've whatever [ __ ] have Ethan
Bradberry what Austin you used to be 15
minutes right someone less your partner
yeah yeah how long we poppin to get like
15 minutes yeah you held it yeah it's
crazy now I don't know it's remember
when I used to make WMDs of like anime
to like making Benjamin do that so
that's classic it's like it's like any
like Linkin Park over Dragon Ball Z
videos way of what you said WME WME I
guess and every time there's like a drop
like there's always some like explosion
yeah it's crazy
all that up I don't know just look up
like Dragon Ball Z Linkin Park w hold up
hold up this is what and I'll see if
it's not uploading in 2005 that's what
up a luck charm buzzy what Linkin Park
he's gonna listen this [ __ ] up pull it
up this is new this I feel like we
covered so much ground in this podcast
is that well forever what's left to talk
about I wanted to show you the Bill Nye
video I feel like we're too deep for
that Bill Nye
has this new Netflix show that is just
absolute cancer
so I want to show you this one clip have
you seen that we must gender fluidity
they removed it I just love the song
crazy we have two conversations this is
high level podcast this is this is
advantage they can replay it and listen
to the other conference right just
playback let me play it's okay there's
really not much to see it's just Dragon
Ball Z with Linkin Park at the back so
this was pretty lit notice this is the
culture was it a joke or you wash it I
love it
Jackie compilation I loved it and do you
remember stick figures I did there was
like stick figure games we could kill
like ltos of people that was before the
internet armor games with yep armor game
yeah before the internet got corrupted
was just like all this just browser
games
what Miniclip calm what do you guys
think about this you can pause that play
what do you think about this I know a
lot of religious peoples do this thing
where they're like if you're an atheist
then you have no moral barometer like if
you don't believe in God then why aren't
you out there raping and killing people
are you religious Austin are you
religious George you're a little right
ah nah uh mmm it's complicated it's
complicated that's fair that's totally
fair answer I don't know I guess I guess
the best way to put it is like what's uh
just open open the [ __ ] I think the best
way what's agnostic agnostic is but
agnostic is if I pity you like I don't
want to say the smartest but that's how
I feel it's like you know like expect
anything like there's
much [ __ ] nobody [ __ ] knows yes
that's what I know and I think about
just like organized religion and [ __ ]
and it's like the wreath day it was just
a easy way to control people with
consequence right consequence like if
you don't do this right you're gonna
burn in hell forever because religion at
its essence is always like a pretty good
day yeah I mean that what it stands for
is great right and there's consequence
to someone telling you that you can't do
this because right no like once like
people in power our establishments
ghetto they use religion as a tool to
control people and knowing what's the
good hell yeah yeah nobody I mean it's
not like I'm matching this picture that
Christians so like you burned forever
and Hellfire it's like really it's kind
of [ __ ] crazy
it seems contradictory to a God all
loving there was no work for you for
even if you like rape kids and you're
like the worst person ever well he's
always forgiving like you know people
are a product of their circumstance but
God gave humans freewill right in the
Bible so let's if you [ __ ] up your
freewill and you do bad [ __ ] I guess
that's the tortured forever Oh perhaps
yeah that's that's so if that's what
this when you say because they say on
one hand you are you have free will God
gave you free will by the other hand
God's all know any will or did Satan
give you free well because wasn't the
free will the first free will was what
never took that yeah and they banished
and he's like [ __ ] you he's like Adam
[ __ ] you I think that's one free really
it's in the Bible yeah it's a that's
that's there it's it's inside it's there
Genesis 3:21 it's right there 4:20
Genesis 4:20 Jax to support 20 but like
um yet see I don't know the whole
biblical sense of a god is strange to me
I mean I believe that there's a [ __ ]
higher-power there's a higher energy
that I mean like like I said earlier
like if you're a negative person your
life is gonna be negative if you're a
positive person then I believe like then
you're gonna transcend and just your
percentage exactly and you know it's
like I watched I was think about like a
cryogenic sleep chamber
is that what it is like what's the
difference in before you were born and
when you're dead nothing
that's just emptiness that's it's not
necessarily dark but it's true people
that you're dying but when you die you
go back to where you were billions of
years before you were born it's the same
place you spent most of eternity there
already it's yeah it's like but eat it's
like you don't know any better
yeah just like you never even existed at
all it's like Kurt Vonnegut I love this
quote they says are you afraid of death
and he goes well I imagine it's like
sleep and I love sleep right
don't you love sleep he's like it's just
like a it's the big sleep that's what
they call it the big sleep what I love
if you guys don't know Kurt Vonnegut
chickened out he's my favorite what does
he do
he's like a science fiction novelist he
wrote like slaughterhouse five
slaughterhouse five cat's cradle
what am i smart house one through four
so those didn't make the cut oh so he's
a worldly didn't make the cut they
didn't make the cut so slaughterhouse
five the premise of that is an
incredible story he will he's a World
War two veteran okay and this is based
on a true story that he lived through
where he was injuries dan do you know
about raised in you guys know about that
place I dunno
so after World War two ended like two
days after the Nazis surrendered
officially the Allies went and bumped
racin was like a historic city in German
Germany said to be one of the most
beautiful cities that ever exists and it
was untouched by the war because it was
just a civilian city there was no
military there two days after the war
ended the Allies England specifically
and I think America they firebomb the
whole [ __ ] City just out of straight
revenge and they killed 300,000
civilians something like that and they
burned the whole city to the ground
it's a true story it's a true story it
happened the bombing of Dresden they
were all hiding in a meat in a meat
factory that's why it's called that was
that was the name so yeah so the bombs
were true
popping he was a prisoner of war with
the Germans and they went underground to
a meat factory called slaughterhouse
five and underneath they heard all the
bombs dropping and shed their under
there for days when they came out the
whole city was leveled tons of dead
civilians and he was ordered by the
Germans that he had to clean up
everything he had to get all the bodies
out all the charred corpses of women and
children and civilians and line him up
so he is kind of the whole story is this
sci-fi weird adventure of him kind of
telling that Reese telling that story
and trying to grapple with it
emotionally through another character he
writes but it's it's fascinating Kurt
Vonnegut no he's American he was a
prisoner of war he was another prisoner
but also he's great because he's also
funny he said it's dark comedy yeah it's
not soup we're like just serious it's
slaughterhouse-five together it's all
book yeah it's a wild wild ride like
there's aliens there's like time
dilation it's a trip it's my favorite
book damn but I don't have to read it
but the bombing of Trajan is really
fascinating should check that out
because you think about the Allies you
know histories written by the victors
and you think about the Allies as like
we wrote in on our [ __ ] horses and
save the day from the Nazis but that
[ __ ] was just pure villain don't [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was just pure villainy I'm
really I'm on my end no all right what
the [ __ ] what does it cut
slaughterhouse-five his books are good
oh good so I should get his whole
discography you could go that I'm good
now we're in your world I guess that's
what you'd call it
alright let's wrap this this is narrated
by James Franco yeah whoo
Kurt Vonnegut is an American Hero he's
like a gem I'd suck him off and that is
it man all right let's wrap it right
let's get some
guys thank you so much for watching they
get everyone who came out and donated
and supported us you can find the
rebroadcast of this episode on all
podcasting apps iTunes Google Play etc
and on the h3 podcast YouTube channel we
will reapplied this full episode there
so you can always catch it there if you
missed the live broadcast we will be
back next Friday 3 p.m. PST and every
Friday after with some hot fresh spicy
someone cooler it's all downhill from
here talking about everything anyway
guys we'll see you next week we love you
we appreciate you thanks for tuning in
and we'll see you there bye guys